25 in your Monday morning so this is not
going to have nearly the impact of
completely shutting down the I-15 not
even the impact of closing Tropicana
however an upcoming week-long closure in
the near East Valley it's worth a heads
up
starting tonight at eight Nevada
Department of Transportation shutting
down east and Westbound Stuart between
Pecos and Sand Hill it's part of the big
project around Charleston in the 95 515
eventually the freeway over Stuart's
going to have a couple of new Lanes well
during the closure crews are going to be
putting in these steel girders to make
that possible
so with the closure there are some
pretty easy workarounds during the
closure you'd probably be better off
going up to Bonanza you could also try
Charleston although most drivers in that
area probably go oh no buckle up drive
carefully please put down that phone and
join the driving to Crazy conversation
at traffic 8 at 8newsnow.com